when people invested in the company did
they buy tokens did they invest in the
corporate did they do both and now you
have this foundation how does this all
architect itself because this is a new
concept that's different than venture
correct
um
it's like a trial by fire this there was
i wouldn't call it an architecture it
was just uh the best we could do given
the resources we had in a really fast
moving environment and i think we did
pretty well mostly because of
folks like cosmos where we followed a
lot of the playbook that they set out
so the idea is that you really want a
decentralized network and
decentralization
really means truly independent operators
of the network that can control or run
the nodes and
maximize the cost to destroy it
literally the network dies if i can go
and wipe out every copy
of the ledger that that's what it means
to kill a network
so
making that as expensive as possible
requires um
many jurisdictions very independent
providers many data centers many humans
right running these running these things
and the effective playbook is to do this
via foundation
switzerland is like a nice place to
start it because they deserved yeah they
have pretty clear laws on digital assets
and to still you're still constrained by
us laws you still can't just like dump
tokens on
on uh on us persons
so you still have to go through the
you know exempt kind of style raises
that you do normally for a venture back
company mostly dealing with us
accredited investors and and so forth
um so let's talk about what people are
building on top of solana because it is
am i correct that this is
essentially like an operating system
where people can build apps on top of it
and how does that manifest itself is
this a specific
uh code base how does one build an
application how sophisticated is that
application language if you were to
compare it to say
building i don't know a a website or
building an app on ios
so um
this kind of really
speaks to my background i spent most of
my career at qualcomm
first big project i was on was brew
which is the kind of the first mobile
platform of us
so the environment for solana is you
build a elf executable object right yeah
that targets berkeley packet filter
which is a bytecode that's got really
high security guarantees with llvm which
is a standard compiler toolchain that if
you've been coding and you've heard of
it
and you can use any front-end language
so c c plus plus rust and we have a
sisters that we built to help you target
the thing and we prefer rust
so it's kind of like building for an
embedded system and
you should think of it as an embedded
system because it is one shared giant
computer for the entire world
and the world is big right
so
if you don't treat it as an embedded
system it becomes very expensive to be
able to host arbitrary applications
because you just can't use a lot of
arbitrary resources would somebody be
able to build an application equivalent
uh to i'll just give two examples here
and we'll walk through it let's say
twitter a basic social network micro
blogging platform or a spotify
on
uh solana currently and when they did
does that mean when they deploy it they
have zero server costs they're just
deploying to the network or they're
paying
you know and so when somebody would
resolve to run spotify or to run twitter
they would be running on the solana
network is that the concept here
so the it's deceptive that if i said yes
it's possible but i'd be lying
because
what you're what the network is scaling
is rights it's simply scaling writing
the writing the state and confirming
that these rights happened got it all
the database component
all the actual hard work in twitter is
on scaling the reads right twitter has
like 5 000 tweets per second we can
handle 5000 transactions per second not
a big deal but how do you globally scale
100 million concurrent reads and
structure this data it's the same work
that twitter does
it's a giant yeah um what do they call
those
non-sql databases i guess that let you
pull up
pre-constructed lists of uh your feed
and that is another type of technical
challenge so what what we would be
saying here in the twitter example is
yes your rights
to your feed could be handled by the
solana network
but the reads would have to be done in
some other place correct correct
and then if you did deploy in this
fashion you basically no longer require
a database
at you know aws or somewhere you're
relying on the solana network to be your
giant database to confirm all of these
tweets in this example um
but you would still have to figure out a
way to have people read it and construct
those feeds which you would do through a
normal
whatever lamp stack or whatever you used
yep exactly
um and then the people running the
network would get paid a fraction of a
penny every time you wrote
a tweet to the network
and you could socialize it from like
your single application server that kind
of feeds
takes in the funnel of human tweets and
then pays for them right and you can
send them ads instead or you could use a
truly self-custody decentralized way
where although your user expected to
have a wallet they have some soul in it
and they just automatically pay every
time they tweet
this would be a way to mitigate against
spam uh and deal with identity on these
networks because if you were running a
bot farm you would all of a sudden have
a cost to everything you published to
the network and so
if twitter wanted to get rid of spam and
bots if they charged a penny every time
you created an account and
you know it was a hundredth of a penny
for your first tweet of the day
a tenth of a penny for your second and a
penny for your
10th whatever it is you could actually
model out a de minimis amount of cost
like something people would never even
notice a dollar a year maybe a dollar
every 10 years but it would be enough to
kill all the bots correct correct
that that is exactly civil resistance
the whole proof of work
reason reason for proof of work to exist
is to kill bots
it's time for another our crowd deal of
the week right now you can join our
crowd's investment in orient according
to the deal mellow orients software only
indoor gps is 20 times more accurate and
scalable than current solutions and
they've landed contracts with some of
the largest retailers of the world so
why join our crowd you ask well our
crowd investors were in early on some of
the best performing ipos of 2019 and
2020 and now you can join them with our
crowd accredited investors can invest
directly easily and most importantly
early our crowd investors have benefited
from companies ipo'ing like beyond me or
being bought by companies like intel
nike microsoft oracle and uber so here's
your old cta the call to action our
crowd's accredited investors have
already invested over one billion
dollars in growing tech companies if
you're an accredited investor you can
join our crowd for free at our
crowd dot com twist and review the
current deals there is no payment
involved until you decide to invest
that's ourcrowd.com ourcrowd.comtwist to
sign up for free